the city of rio de janeiro is going all
in on bitcoin in a recent interview the
secretary of finance and planning said
that rio de janeiro is looking to the
city of miami as inspiration they want
to accept bitcoin for tax payments they
want to integrate bitcoin and the
lightning network into a number of their
services and they also are looking at
the possibility of buying bitcoin and
putting it on the city's balance sheet
in this interview we see the thought
process that cities around the world are
starting to turn to whether they live in
high inflation or they simply are
worried about human-led variable
monetary policy they realize that the
future is digital and they realize that
the future is programmatic monetary
policy and now they are asking
themselves should we act today or do we
have a little bit more time before we
are going to have to do something in
this interview andrea senko rio de
janeiro secretary of finance and
planning was asked about the idea of the
city integrating bitcoin cinco responded
rio because of its vocation as a global
city is aware of the world's main
changes and innovations and always
places itself at the forefront of these
issues the city looks to the future and
the city hall has been following the
technological and economic advances the
goal is to make rio the crypto ecosystem
of brazil contributing to the city
becoming the innovation and technology
capital of the country to help with that
integration they then were asked about
the activities under discussion by the
institution there senko stated that the
municipal committee for crypto
investments established in march of 2022
works on a policy for investment in
crypto assets and a governance model for
decision making and then lastly cinco
was asked about the idea of the city
putting bitcoin on their balance sheet
and he stated that this purchase will
follow a methodology that is attentive
to the swings and risks of this market
and is under development by city hall it
is absolutely incredible to see a major
city like rio de janeiro not only
understanding the technology behind
bitcoin but also realizing the benefits
of a programmatic monetary policy and
realizing that there are multiple ways
for them to take their city and plug it
into the bitcoin network more and more
young leaders are getting into positions
of power and influence and they
understand that they must embrace
technology and part of embracing
technology and innovation is embracing
bitcoin whether they are going to buy
bitcoin they are going to accept bitcoin
they are going to pay their employees in
bitcoin or they want to start to
participate in things like bitcoin
mining bitcoin is going to become a
cornerstone of local economies because
bitcoin is good for individuals bitcoin
is good for companies and eventually we
are going to realize that bitcoin is
good for government any time that you
can leverage a programmatic monetary
policy with a censorship resistant
digital decentralized currency
it looks like signal among the noise
against the backdrop of undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy in the fiat
world rio understands that this is where
the world is moving
they're early they got a lot of work to
do they've got to figure out how exactly
they're going to interface with the
technology and how they are going to
integrate it into their products and
services but this is something that we
should commend and everyone around the
world should do our best to try to help
them realize where's the viable path
forward how can they use this technology
to help the millions of their citizens
because if they get it right they'll
serve as just another example of what i
believe most cities around the world
will eventually do hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time